a baseball is big in this community here
in centennial hills just take a look at
this monument here put for the 2014
little league champions that came here
from the mountain ridge little league
well when parents here found out about
their snack shack being broken into
they're upset and heartbroken
and when she went into the door she
realized that the deadbolt hadn't been
locked on thursday a parent of a
mountain ridge baseball little league
player noticed something was wrong with
the snack bar she walked in and then
immediately realized that something
wasn't right the freezer door was open
it was empty the cash register when she
checked it was empty jimmy bellinger is
the league president he says someone
went through and took six thousand five
hundred dollars worth of items big
ticket items they took
seven of our 10
pa speakers our scoreboard controllers
that run our scoreboards and the most
expensive device was our defibrillator
the season is set to end in just a few
weeks normally we'd set those pa systems
up and have
national anthem starting lineups and
music in between innings we're not going
to be able to do that we don't have the
equipment now bellinger says they have
insurance but it won't cover everything
so one parent created a gofundme to help
the little league out and it's just kind
of the timing makes it really tough to
give the same stuff that we would for a
normal end of season the mountain ridge
league is home to the 2014 national
champions he says this community loves
baseball we've never had anything like
this he says this impacts the players
and the whole ridge baseball family for
people to come in here and take it it's
it's
just
it breaks my heart it's hard to take